one of the things that you will quickly
experience if you get into this and most
of you probably already know is that
rational and by that I mean
statistically extrapolate able
expectations seem to be superseded on
these trips by a kind of magical
connectedness all kinds of strange
things happen on trips that really
happen it's not hallucination these
things really happen it's almost as
though ordinary laws of causality are
obviated and you become a magnet for the
strange the peculiar and sometimes these
synchronicities are trivial sometimes
they're the difference between life and
death
as an example of the latter I've told
this story before but one time years ago
Dennis and that girlfriend of his went
up into the mountains behind a boulder
and they took our jariya and their votes
of Hawaiian baby would rose it was much
stronger than they expected and it
lasted much longer than they expected
and so night fell and behind boulder up
around Netherland it's thirty twelve
thousand feet I mean when night falls
the temperature plummets you're
immediately in the situation of crisis
night fell they were completely lost
they had no clue where they were or how
to get back to the car and it looked
grim and so they're looking out over
these valleys and mountains and so forth
trying to spot something and finally
across the valley they see what my
brother assumes is a car has come around
the corner because they see the
headlights and so they descend down in
this Canyon it takes them an hour it's
pitch dark they climb up the other side
and they are to arrive in a parking lot
to find their color not only to find
their car but to find that the lights
are on
well they had left the car some 12 hours
before the battery would have been run
down if the lights had been on all that
time
it means the light they saw the lights
come on when they looked out across the
valley full of fear wondering where they
were so you know it's just the story
unless you're the person whose life was
saved by this incident so and you can
see them why Aboriginal people would
have this faith in the primacy of mine
probably because mine disinfect primary
and it's only because we've lost
ourselves down into a set of
reductionist expectations that we live
in a world so so brutally under the
aegis of laws like entropy and see
reality and so forth and so on
[Music]
you